hey guys pete here fargo season 4 has
come to an end
a history lesson on the alternate
economy of kansas city set the stage for
a full-blown gang war
that consumed the city as 1950 gave way
to 1951.
as we've come to expect from fargo it
has no shortage of interesting
characters
career criminals law enforcement
officers
and of course some civilians who find
themselves caught up in the action
season 4 gave us a whole gang of
underdogs
a failed son who finds himself in charge
of his connected mafia family
an angel of death who has an affinity
for baking
a chatty mormon us marshall who's earned
the nickname
deffy because he only hears what he
wants to hear a duo of escaped convicts
who fancy themselves as
outlaws rather than criminals a student
who happens on her next-door neighbor's
deadly secret
and a local cop who the u.s military
thought would make a great minesweeper
even though he's plagued with nervous
ticks fargo's fourth season
also gave us the origin story of a fan
favorite character from season 2
and the showrunner has provided some
additional context for that
in his post-finale interviews which i'll
get into in a little while
before we begin as is tradition this is
your spoiler warning
if you haven't watched all 11 episodes
of fargo season 4 then this video will
absolutely spoil it
my goal here is to explain the ending
after all i'm also going to talk about
some of the previous seasons
so if you're a late comer to the series
it's something to think about however i
don't think that will spoil those
seasons any more than watching season 4
would
with that out of the way let's get
started if you followed along with my
season 4 episode recap and reviews
you know i had some problems with this
season compared to the previous
installments
at the same time it had some great ideas
and some great characters
all served up in a great looking period
piece that boasted some gorgeous
cinematography
so today i just wanted to talk about the
ending what noah holly might have been
trying to say
what the ending means for kansas city
and its characters
what the ending means for the rest of
the series and in the end
what's worth remembering fargo always
features at least one character that
could be described as inherently good
you've got all these criminal types
running around doing their thing
and on the other side you've got your
lou and molly solversons
and your gloria burgles these are
usually cops
they're usually white and so season four
changes this
up our moral center this time around is
ethel rita pearl smutny a biracial teen
whose parents find themselves
caught up with the local black criminal
outfit their attempt to pay off their
debt to lloyd cannon
using money that zelmer and swaney stole
from him
creates a situation where he takes over
their family business
in the end it's ethereda's wits that
help her family come away with a happy
ending
she uses donatello fada's ring which she
found in orienta mayflower's apartment
to broker a deal with loy cannon and
help him win his war
in the 10th episode we see her pick up a
pair of suitcases and leave in the
finale and the showrunner has confirmed
that she makes it out in the end he said
that her reward for surviving the story
is that she goes off and has an
unremarkably positive life she's going
to move to paris she's going to become a
writer and she's going to prosper
outside of america she knows in that
moment that she can't prosper inside
america
and she has the wherewithal to get out
and the season as a whole fits into her
school history report which the season
opens
and closes with i'll get into that
history report at the end but for now
let's look at the different sides of the
gang war
and how things played out for each side
in the season finale
josto finds himself as the boss of the
foda family
after he makes an offhanded comment
about his father
to a nurse that he got some drugs off of
she turned out to be a serial killer
she killed his father and since their
outfit is structured as a family
business
that means he's now in charge he's not
really the right guy for the job
by the time we reach the finale that
ring i mentioned that ethel rita gave
over to lloyd cannon
is now in the hands of the family's
concierie
who accuses him of killing his father in
order to take over the business
and they've bailed his accomplice out of
jail who's more than happy to cop to the
murder
josto isn't a sympathetic character he's
pretty much an incompetent arrogant ass
when it comes down to it but that isn't
all there is to his story
after all he was traded away as a child
just like satchel and rabbi
and we know he was the victim of abuse
in that situation
in the end he did start the whole gang
war but it was by accident
and abel used that opportunity to his
own advantage
his story winds up being tragic in that
he reconciles with his brother
only to see him die shortly afterward
and then his own people take him down
for the crime of taking power for
himself with abel using that as a
vehicle to do the exact same
thing orienta's confession is enough to
earn them both a bullet in the head
and she manages to salt his wounds by
requesting that he's killed first so
that she can watch him die
before he goes he makes the case that
his own men killing him is what they
want us to do
it's a ladder but there's nowhere to go
and that is where he found himself he
made it to the top
and wound up at the bottom of an
unmarked grave in the middle of nowhere
this did make for my favorite sequence
of the finale
and that had a lot to do with my
favorite character of season 4 orienta
mayflower
we see that she does enjoy watching this
lover of hers die
and when it's her turn she doesn't seem
all that worried about it
there was one curious thing here that i
missed in my previous video
and that's that when she's looking at
her reflection we also see the
reflection of the ghost
aka mr snowman aka captain
roach i don't have a great explanation
for why the ghost is now following her
but this could be a bright spot
considering that this might mean
that he doesn't follow the smutney
family anymore
on the canon side of things loy almost
makes it out
on top he's able to dispatch leon and
his uncle happy
who double-crossed him siding with josto
he finds out that his son
who he traded for power who he thought
had died
did manage to make it home at this point
all the work and all the sacrifices seem
to have paid off
and then things take a turn when he
realizes that abel vellante
who's now in charge of the family won't
honor their deal
it's a situation where abel knows he has
the power behind him
so he sees no reason to give anything to
loy
this is something we'd seen throughout
the season in episode 1 ethel rita
described it like this
whoever was last off the boat finding
the doors of honest capital clothes
rolled up their sleeves and got to work
getting rich the old-fashioned way
so these different ethnic criminal gangs
essentially turn to crime
as a way to make a living as immigrants
they're all seen as outsiders
but loy and his people are in a
different situation
because they're black they'll never be
able to assimilate into that society
in the same way and we saw this with the
credit card he had a great idea
we all know how that would turn out but
rather than cut him in
the bank manager just took his idea and
made it his own
with no real fear of that coming back on
him so in the finale we see loy cut out
we see him lose all his power
and then we see him return home seeing
his family together
and having that moment of clarity where
he realizes he may not get that but he
does have this
in noah halley's words loy realizes i
thought i needed more power to keep him
safe and now that i have no power
no one is after us and maybe this is a
good thing he has this moment where he
thinks maybe this is a happy ending
and then of course we know how that ends
zelmer roulette
returns to avenge her lost lover swanny
capps
she stabs loy multiple times and he dies
and what's interesting about that is
that she does this in retaliation
he gave them train tickets he sent them
away and then he went back on
his word he told the cops where they
were going
and so as it usually does in this
universe the things you do can come back
to you
and this one decision does him in
i mentioned him trading his son for
power the idea there that we saw had
been going on for generations without
much luck
was that each family would trade a son
and that would prevent the escalation of
hostilities
when josto was going to break that deal
and have satchel killed rabbi milligan
swooped in to save him
before he was carried away to his end by
a tornado
he'd been taking the majority of his
time taking care of satchel
and preparing him for the world his
motivation was that he wanted
satchel to have a choice rabbi was made
a child soldier
as were many of the kids in these
families they didn't have a say in it
so when the war breaks out he takes him
away leaving satchel on his own with
this new dog rabbit that he found in
their hotel
ultimately he decides to go home to his
family where he gets a brief reunion
that ends in watching his father die
right in front of him
now i mentioned that ethel rita and her
family made it out with a happy ending
and as the story teller the one that
explained this world that these
characters inhabit and the things that
they're up against
i think she wraps it up really nicely in
the ending of her report
she says history is a form of memory but
what does it mean to remember
ask yourself who writes the books who
chooses what to remember
and what gets forgotten and damn it if
it isn't satchel
aka mike milligan this is his memory
this is what we see
him thinking about when we see the
images overlapped where we see him
riding down the road
we see the image of satchel and rabbit
making their way
thinking about rabbi who always warned
him if he didn't return then he was
either dead or in jail
we see mike milligan taking the clip out
of his gun and putting in the next one
in the exact same way we saw a rabbi
doing that earlier in the season
and we see that all of this that's
happened satchel cannon slash mike
milligan
he's the one that carries the memory
when we meet him again in 1979
we see that he ends up working for the
organization that took his father down
of course he knows it was zelmer that
actually killed him but his conflict
with the fadas is what brought him to
that place
again to reference the showrunner when
asked about what happens between satchel
being on the porch and watching his
father die
in the moment where we meet mike years
later he said his feeling was that the
family wasn't able to stay in that house
their source of revenue dried up after
lloyd died
that they inevitably went through some
hard times in that then
ultimately satchel didn't have a lot of
opportunity in his life
and he had to go back to those skills he
learned from rabbi
he said that on some level the moment
his dad was killed in front of him he
didn't really have that choice that
rabbi wanted him to have
anymore and that he had to change his
name because being a cannon wasn't a
safe thing to be
so he chose the milligan name then at a
certain point having laundered his
identity he started pulling jobs of some
kind
and ended up in the kansas city mafia
which is ultimately what became of the
thought of family business when abel
took over
in a different interview when asked why
he wanted to tell mike milligan's story
holly said i suppose on some level the
story is an attempt to explain the
origins of someone as unique as him
the idea that he's canon's son but
raised by a second father
who himself was raised by irish and
jewish and italian parents
and on some level that's the history of
america right there
in season two we also see what becomes
of abel's vision
we see joe bulow still in a role with
the organization and we see his
interactions with the gerhart family he
mentions the problems he has with the
family business
and now we know where those beliefs came
from it's all a reflection of the bigger
picture
in the 1950s all these gangs of others
were stirred up fighting against each
other rather than the system that put
him in that position
as time goes on power's consolidated and
smaller outfits are absorbed like all
the mom and pop shops that go out of
business when walmart moves in
there really was no place for the cannon
syndicate in that new kansas city
we also see what's to become a mort
kellerman after he killed josto and
gautano's mother
and it will be interesting to watch it
again with all this new information
and with that i think i've touched on
all the things i wanted to when i set
out to make this video today
if you're looking for a more in-depth
breakdown and critique i did all the
episodes except number seven in this
season
and in my finale video i gave my overall
review for the season
i will say that after reading all these
interviews
it does sound like there's a really good
chance we'll get more fargo in the
future
at least one more season no guarantees
there of course but
it's clear there's interest when you
hear him talk about this story
i think i probably have one more fargo
video coming this weekend
i'm thinking of doing one where i look
at all the different connections across
the seasons
so please like this video if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon